are the talking of musical icons
kristen's got thomas
you were discovered by a musical icon i
was yeah
this is an amazing story i did not know
this story go somebody said that hand
picked by prince
prince prince you like saying that don't
you
and you should yeah so i was 22
23 working in the theater in france and
i got a call to go
um to a casting because prince is going
to make a film
in france and he needs um people to play
the small
roles and he wants local actresses so he
doesn't have to import any
english speakers from elsewhere so i
show up
do this audition and then they said
would you be interested in auditioning
for the lead
i just simply first of all i i thought
the whole thing was just a miracle me
even being there because that was the
summer of around the world in a day and
i had been listening to it
over and over again on repeat on my
walkman that somebody brought me back
from japan
because they were a rarity do you
remember those
things like this yeah yeah and so i
didn't said
yes and then um you know i did some more
words and my head was spinning slightly
and then they said um
can you come back at about six to meet
prince and i i
promise you it was i had to keep
reminding myself that this is
actually real this is actually going on
and
um i went back met him
got the job he actually flung a piece of
bread across the dining room but that
was a mistake
but he was a bit nervous i think really
yeah i had a sort of nervous gesture we
was only we were
lit we were children we were 20 23 and
22.
and the movie was called under the
cherry moon we've got a picture of you
and prince in the movie oh god
there you are wow look at him
look at you yes and then and then you
brought your mom
to the premiere which must be lovely for
her well she yes i mean
yeah it was a weird premiere because it
was in wyoming
and they took over the whole town it was
this huge great deal
and mummy came
and after the premiere she patted my
knee
we were sitting together and then she
goes
don't worry darling it'll be better next
time
and she was right
you